This is the Chris Abraham show.
Hey, this is Chris Abraham from
The Chris Abraham Show.
It is Monday, December 22nd and
I'm going to start a new season.
I forget what season it is.
So whatever season it was, it is
one season more.
And I have not done a Live Human
Chris Abraham podcast for an
entire year.
I think I've been writing
substacks that I've been feeding
to that I've been feeding to
notebook LM and then have been
uploading as a podcast.
At first I actually had my own
recordings and then had them
transcribe and then uploaded
them to notebook LM.
But then I pivoted and started
doing sub stacks and so I just
went completely all AI.
Like all I would do is
orchestrate.
Like I like to say that I'm like
Rubens or Rembrandt where I have
a school of painting and I just
come up with the idea and maybe
sketch it out.
And then I have a room full of
AIS going ahead and filling out
the artwork, filling out the
podcast words, creating the
entire sub stack.
And all I do is act as the
editor who revises and revises
and revises until it's kind of
the same kind of point that I
want my entire idea.
If it's manifest then I post it
as my as my own but it's all AI
anyway.
But it did start a lot of
conversations which makes me
happy.
I think that if I had a DJ name
it would be DJ slop or AI slop
DJ slop.
But I think that I'm probably
the least heinous user.
So what's going on?
I don't know.
I had my second ablation one
week ago and my heart is humming
along.
For those of you who don't know
I had I got a arrhythmia and
I've been struggling with sinus
rhythm and a an ablation is
actually a relatively invasive
but sophisticated surgery that
goes in and like zaps nerve
impulses that are not consistent
with the sinus rhythm.
So it goes in there and tries to
map and then discontinue
extraneous impulses that result
in in arrhythmia and in my case,
atrial fibrillation.
So the second one seemed to
work, the first one didn't, and
it really dispirited me.
I think that dispiritedness
resulted in me gaining all my
weight back and now I'm working
hard and also probably buying
some Ozempic type stuff to
really kind of get back into the
saddle.
Because I feel good now, right?
My heart is working correctly
and I'm sleeping well and I'm on
bi pap and all the other old guy
things that I'm doing. 20 years
ahead of everybody else, I
guess.
But hopefully because I'm in
sinus rhythm, I'll be able to
get out some of the get off some
of the drugs I'm on like the
anti arrhythmia medication or
maybe even the blood thinners,
who knows.
But yeah, I'm hoping that I am
out and about.
More often people are wondering
why the ubiquitous walking
around the neighborhood, Chris
Abraham isn't walking around the
neighborhood ubiquitously.
And that's really just me,
right?
I mean, the lethargy is real,
it's no joke.
So I did cancel my year
commitment to cycle bar, but I
really want to go there.
But until I get back on the
saddle and literally get back on
the saddle, I have a stationary
bike, a Kaiser M3, and I have a
Surly Steamroller, a single
speed, three single speed city
bike that I turn into a three
speed with an internal hub, My
pride and joy.
And once I kind of get back into
the saddle and I'm also getting
back to my kettle bells, which I
had right before I made a turn
in the wrong direction.
I went to a courthouse area, was
a courthouse, a courthouse
adjacent tattoo parlor and
literally had a competition
style kettlebell.
No actually it's a a cast iron
hard style kettlebell tattooed
on the web of my left hand and
then proceeded never to touch a
kettlebell ever again.
It was that one of those last
gasp things like I'm having a
struggle to do it so if I tattoo
it on my hand then maybe it'll
make me do it.
So probably also going to get a
concept 2 logo and also a muted
horn.
A mute horn, muted horn icon
from Thomas Pynchon's book,
Crying of Lot 49.
Other than that, business has
been going well.
I've been doing a lot of Google
Business page recovery and I've
been doing a lot of SEO and a
lot of artificial intelligence
SEO as well.
And other than that, I don't
even know if I have the audio
editing tool download it into my
Linux box.
What else nerdy thing that I did
recently 2 very nerdy things
that I am really proud of 1 is I
installed.
I don't know if you guys ever
seen or read or watched the
series of Ghost in the shell.
The legit comic strip version
cartoon version, but they're
these little blue robots these
little blue tanks.
The name eludes me, but I'll
include it in the show notes.
And they're my favorite thing
about Ghost in the Shell because
there's these little, these
little battle bots, these little
autonomous battle bots that are
synced via a, a satellite, a
satellite server and they
collaborate and they back
themselves up.
They back their souls, if you
will.
They're they do full backups to
the server every night.
And upon the growth of the, as
the story develops, you start to
realize that at one point you
realize that at one point the
little blue battle tanks, the
adorable comic, the adorable
Comic Relief battle tanks are
now sentient.
And they have their own agency
and their own knowledge, their
own loyalty and their own tribal
nature and their love for each
other.
In Loki, they kind of worship
the satellite that they sink to,
and they consider the backups to
be their souls, which is cool.
So I was thinking about that and
I decided that I wanted every
single one of my 7 identical
X220 Lenovo Thinkpads circa
2011, each installed with Linux
Mint.
I wanted every single one of
them to have the exact same
document folder.
So I was working for one client
and they had a pretty cool like
application environment where
you could create a droplet,
which a droplet is basically
like a virtual Linux box, a
virtual server, and you have a
lot of control over it.
And it's great for git based
application environments.
And so I did the application for
the client and then I went ahead
and turned around and create a
little 8 GB to droplet or 25.
I think it's a 25 GB, maybe a 10
or 8 or five.
However big it is.
It I set it up using this really
cool Linux command LINE app
called Sync Thing.
And Sync Thing isn't a backup
device.
It's not a network backup
It is a node in a sync network.
I love the fact that the TV show
Pluribus happened right when I
started doing these things
because it's very mesh network.
Because I also out of nowhere
decided to join the Mesh Tastic
network.
I plan to do it forever.
But the final straw was that
Adam Curry was talking about
Mesh Tastic on the No Agenda
show.
So I decided to look for a cheap
one that would allow me to put
my foot in and I found one on
Etsy that was fully done based
on the H3 internals in a little
vice that's called the H1 and
got it home.
And now I'm the Abra node is
Arlington Heights, Virginia, and
the full name is Abracadabra
because I initially called it
Abraham, but that's just a
little bit, not private enough.
So I made that and it's really
cool.
It's been up for five days now,
completely autonomous, hanging
from my 8th floor window,
looking out through an open
window so that there's not the
glass restriction.
And it's very cool.
It's stupid, but it's very cool
because it's not a vigorous and
rigorous Discord like chat
space.
There is a there is a chat area,
a group chat area, everybody
who's locally connected through
an emergent mesh network.
And the cool thing about this
device, this meshtastic device,
which is a little a little
purple plastic 3D printed
enclosure that has inside of it
a little OLED screen and it's
got the radio circuits and it's
got AI guess a foot long whip
antenna and and a USBC and a low
energy Bluetooth.
And it just sits there and it
says hello world.
And it's like it takes advantage
of a of a Gray area where it can
be secure, it can be encrypted.
You don't need a ham license or
any FCC license.
You just turn it on and you
become part of the mesh and you
become an essential part of the
network and you make the network
stronger.
It's sort of like being a, being
a note on a, on a Bitcoin
network or on an Ethereum
network, right?
As long as you go ahead and
become part of the of the mining
and become part of the the
Ledger, then you are a valuable
contributor and you add to the
health of the network.
And there's no chatting in terms
of voice, no voice, no Morse
code, nothing.
It is exclusively short message.
It's not rich message and it's
and it's either peer-to-peer as
in Adm or it uses the network
kind of like is a TCPIP network
or it uses the network as a
mailbox relay.
And there's repeaters which are
similar to ham.
But it is also very similar to
really early nascent DARPA
Internet type of things, except
instead of using CAT5 or or T1
cables, it uses radio waves.
Which was a perfect, perfect
thing that in my life I
spontaneously, even before the
Apple plus Apple TV Gilligan
production of Pluribus PLUR, the
sorry PLUR, the the number 1B
USPLURIBUS, but in the typefaces
PLUR number one, the one numeral
BUS.
And it's an amazing it's an
amazing show.
And there's nothing I can tell
you at all about it because I
want you to experience it fresh
and I don't want you to know
anything about it.
But maybe you can intuit that I
was so excited to be a brand new
node on an emergent prepper
radio based mesh network that I
could either peer-to-peer DM or
there is AI guess one would call
it a, a group text where you
post to a group text and whoever
is within the sound of your mesh
network will be able to see
that.
But most of the time it's like,
can you hear me from Adams
Morgan?
You know, I can hear you or I
can hear you in three hops.
OK, so you understand how a mesh
network works, especially you
guys who are in Modern Warfare
or understand how how those
little understand how those what
are those called?
They're called tags or etags or
whatever work, right?
Like it's, it's a local network
based on everybody who allows
their little mesh tastic device
to be transmitting and receiving
as a node or as a repeater on
the network.
You don't have to organize it
with somebody.
You don't need to say hello
world.
You don't have to say a thing.
All you need to do is turn it
on, set it up, tell it how many
hops or jumps you're willing to
go.
Apparently best practices say
that you stay at 3, but there's
also 5:00 and 7:00.
And then you get to see on this
live little network via
Bluetooth on my Android phone,
what's going on?
How many nodes are local?
I set it up so that it also
connects my phone to the
Internet and then reports that
my network exists on the
Internet so that people can see
it.
Is it MTQQMTQQ?
Something like that?
It was really thrilling to go on
to the Internet, mash mesh
tastic map and be able to see
Abra in the vicinity of
Arlington Heights S Arlington,
VA.
It's not precise.
I'd like it to be more precise,
but maybe I should hardwire the
address into the device and not
just rely on here I am stuff
triangulation anyway, so yeah.
So after spontaneously joining a
mesh tastic network as a node
with the short code abra in the
long code abracadabra because
Abraham felt too intimate, I had
aspirations of buying a repeater
and spending spending spending.
But I realized that the fact
that I have a reliable node even
though I haven't updated my
firmware means that I'm value
add to the community.
Most of the meta conversation
happens on Discord though, and I
think it's like mesh dc.org
maybe.
Anyway, it's very exciting.
It's very exciting.
I was very excited last time we
spoke about my Abraham dot SU
Mastodon server, and I almost
shut it down.
It would have been shut down
today or yesterday, but I went
in and rescued it last minute.
Apparently the SU Soviet Union
top level domain is going to go
out of business in 20-30.
So I really only have four years
left.
So I'll commit to hosting
Mastodon for another four years
until it goes bye bye and then
I'll give up on Mastodon.
I also, thanks to Jason Guljar,
I also set up a micro dot blog
account and while everybody was
doing everything cool, I scored
Chris a dot micro dot blog.
And then while everybody was
trying to be cool, I decided to
search for a domain name to go
with my microblog and I was able
to register Chris ACH risa.org,
which I think is freaking
awesome.
So cool.
So now I'm Chris a.org.
In the microblog world, I am
Abraham dot SU.
In the world of Mastodon, I am
chrisabraham.com.
In the world of websites, I am
chris-abraham.com.
In the world of Tumblr.
And I don't know what else.
So yeah, you all have to see
Pluribus.
See it, see it all before
Friday.
Friday is the final episode and
the season finale.
Ever since our our our spoken
word Chris Abraham old man
podcast, I have, I don't know if
I mentioned it, but it's been a
while.
So I joined a dungeon Dragon's
quest and it is the curse of
Stroud.
And I've been going on to
Discord, video on the discord
dedicated to this curse of
Stroud campaign run by
apparently the DND famous Sean
Scanlon.
And I'm also on there with
apparently D&D famous Carrie
Abend, Abend Abend.
And I'm on there with Tripp and
other Sean and Enrique.
And depending on whether we can
get a quorum of three, we play.
So we played on Saturday from
noon till 5.
We try to do Saturdays, noon to
4-5 or six, depending on
availability.
One of our guys is in Germany
outside of Frankfurt, so he's
actually quite a bit later.
And it's like night night when
we're day day and it's so fun.
My name is Radley, and I am a
I'm a human fighter, and I have
spells, which means I'm a
eldritch night, I think, and I
refuse to read the player's
manual, so it's very slow going
in.
The DM is very frustrated with
me, and we're running it off of
D&D Beyond.
So all the rolling, all of the
initiative, all of the saving
throws, all of the two hits and
damages are all done through
virtual dice in the system.
And all of our characters are
run on D&D Beyond character
sheets.
And all the maps and all the
fighting and all the everything
is run by Sean via the Dungeon
Master Tools and D&D Beyond.
And he's mostly frustrated, but
I'm mostly impressed.
And so it's slow going.
We constantly roll terribly.
We constantly throw ourselves at
danger and then handle
everything terribly.
We always zig when Sean prepares
for us and expects us to zag and
it's a lot of fun.
Everybody's face is on video.
We're all old dudes and even my
friend Linda who I want to start
a podcast with, even she is
surprised how old and grizzled
we all are.
So it's hilarious.
So laugh riot.
I love it very much.
So the fact that I watch
pluribus have a meshtastic node
have oh back to sink thing
which.
Which is where I started.
So now are they takayamas?
Takidamas Takidoris.
Anyway, the name of the blue
tanks in Ghost in the Shell who
become sentient, sync their
souls with a server.
So I haven't committed to this
yet because every one of my
Linux boxes have a unique Lenovo
or ThinkPad based pun named like
like I know Lenovo or I don't
know Lenovo.
Is that already?
So anyway, they're all either
ThinkPad, Lenovo or Linux based
node names.
I have 7X2 twenties, none of
them are ever open at the same
time.
And I have a a W 520, which I
call the Big Bertha.
I call it mento.
I don't know why I call it
mento.
Can you think of why I would
call the Big Bertha Mento
anyway?
So each one of them is a node
and they're connected to this
droplet.
And the droplet is not a backup
place.
It is a it is a sync point.
It doesn't backup.
What it does is its only job is
to make sure that every time one
of the boxes, one of the 8 Linux
Mint Lenovo ThinkPad boxes that
I have come online, every moment
that happens, it pings the
droplet and it checks to see
whether or not the documents on
its local hard drive are the
same as the documents on the
droplet.
And then it syncs them.
It moves all the documents that
are not on that local box onto
the documents folder on that
box.
And then make sure any documents
that are on the local box are
synced with the, with the sync
thing droplet box.
And then when it finally syncs
and everything sorted that it
just it stops unless anything
changes.
And then when I'm done with the
day, I close that box and let's
say I open another box.
And then after updating it for
like a million years with, with
update modules and universal
updates and, and flat pack and
all that other fun stuff.
Then automagically think thing
comes up, looks for the droplet
server and does the same check
and then uploads all the
documents that it has on that
box, syncs it to the droplet.
And then the droplet syncs all
the ones that are on the
droplet, but not the not the,
not the box that I just opened.
And then it deals with any
conflicts.
It does a concurrence check.
It checks to see and apparently
sync thing is extremely
sophisticated.
And so the silliness that I'm
making it do or like an insult,
you know, like Marvin the
Martian are Marvin the Marvin
the sorry Marvin the robot is
always insulted by the menial
tasks he has to do.
Considering that he knows
everything about everything, he
could do everything and is has a
brain bigger than the universe.
I'm just making him sync files
off of between asynchronously
opened slave boxes and like the
the droplet is kind of like the
master.
And each time I open up a new
box, I have to install think
thing.
I have to make sure it's it
checks, it works and I have like
1-2 three boxes out of eight.
But you know, it doesn't take
that long, but there's always a
problem.
And then once it's sorted, it
means that every time I open up
and it's not a backup thing,
like my document folder is so
minimal, but I didn't want like
something like I didn't want
something like Dropbox or
whatever.
I wanted something geekier and
tech year and cooler.
So yeah, that's what I'm doing.
So that makes me happy.
That takes up time that I can't
bill until I get them all done
and then they're done and
they're working.
But they're not backing up.
They're just, they're just
redistributing across all
networks.
And the only reason that the
droplet needs to exist is
because all boxes will not be
open.
No two boxes will.
The only box that will be always
on the droplet, all the other
boxes will be on.
Periodically they'll say hello
world.
They'll say here are the
documents I've made.
Here are the documents I've
deleted.
changed.
What documents are up on droplet
that I don't have?
What droplets have changed on
droplet that I don't have?
What documents have been deleted
on Droplet that I don't know,
that I don't, that I haven't
deleted?
So and then there's the
Meshtastic, and then there's
D&D.
And then you have to see
Pluribus.
I wish I could share about
I'm not going to share about
Pluribus until the final episode
because I would have completely
made this entire episode about
Pluribus.
However, when I was on my last
step, my last game last
Saturday, which was the 20th
nobody.
And they're all sci-fi geeks.
They're all complete.
Like, like they're all sci-fi
and superhero and like cosplay
games and gaming and like cons
like conferences and pop culture
references guys.
And none of them had heard about
Pluribus.
And unless I've been universally
gas lit, which there's no agenda
to it 'cause I'm happily
enjoying it.
I'm even on the Pluribus.
I'm even on the Pluribus Discord
and on the Pluribus subreddits.
And I watch all the Pluribus
you.
But I love it that Pluribus is
going to be my my Better Call
Saul or my The Wired or those
kinds of series.
It's so good and it made me
think of mesh networks.
And of course, the only thing I
can tell you is that the reason
why the entire world, everybody
is part, everybody became a node
and a mesh network.
And every node is welcome and
every node uses body electrical
field and every node has a is
part of a mesh.
So it's very fascinating.
Maybe they maybe they have
repeaters, maybe the satellites,
maybe all the technology in the
sky, maybe Glonaz and GPS, maybe
Elon Musk's Starlink.
Maybe all of those devices are
repeaters for the radio
frequency that connects all of
the visitors together into their
mesh network.
But I felt all of a sudden
really groovy being part being
literally a node and also having
sync thing running between all
of my boxes.
And that reminds me, I need to
re watch the entire all the
episodes and all the series and
all the seasons and all the
cartoons of Ghosts in the Shell
because it's been since the been
since the mid 2000s since I've
seen them.
And the only reason I saw them
is because I rented the Netflix
DVDs.
I literally saw a Ghost in the
Shell based on Netflix DVDs on a
cathode raid, a cathode ray
television.
No shit.
Anyway, I think that's it.
It was really great talking to
you.
I don't know if anybody is still
listening, but it was great to
catch up with you.
I will spend the rest of this
year catching up with you and
then maybe we will talk about
particularly important thing.
Epstein, literally Hitler,
Russian Ukraine war, Israel and
Palestine, populist nationalism,
all that fun stuff that you know
that I will shamelessly share
what little I know.
But until then, until the first
of the year, it'll just be Chris
Abraham catch up and talking to
you about my nerdy little
delights and just personal
things.
Oh, this is weird.
I've actually become quite
dedicated to the gospels of
Jesus.
Who would have thought that?
And I listened to Hello, which
you've seen all over your online
and TV and YouTube and podcast
and radio advertisements and I
don't know, pretty awesome.
But it's limited to the Gospels.
I am going to just read and
reread the Gospels until the
cows come home, and then when I
feel like I know them and I'm
integrated with them, then I'll
explore other parts of the New
Testament.
And then I'm also trying to
enjoy as many episodes of
Complin of the Episcopalian
Complin as I can.
At night I think complin is
really nice, but I'll listen to
any of the other morning, noon,
and night and go to bed.
Episcopalian prayers, I really
love them.
They're just so beautifully
written and they, you know, use
part of the Psalms or it's just
good stuff.
So anyway, that's new.
And are you going to be playing
the lottery tonight?
It's over $1.6 billion on
Powerball.
I am definitely going to waste.
Is it tonight?
I'm going to waste $20 on it.
So we'll see what happens.
I probably am not going to re re
up my my my membership to TTJTJ
gym, TJ community gym, TCTJ
community gym until tomorrow
evening.
I'm got such a late start.
It's actually 321 now and I
really kind of just checked my
e-mail and did some random
stuff.
I know this is a Christmas funk,
but starting tomorrow morning I
hope to swing some kettle bells
and maybe use my TRX.
And I'm even planning on getting
my butt tough enough to be able
to do some of my work from the
gelled saddle of my Kaiser M3.
And when I finally deferralize
my apartment, I'm going to get
back onto my rowing machine,
which makes me very sad that I
have it up on its nose with its
tail up in the air.
Anyway, Aloha, mahalo Nuiloa.
Thank you very much.
I really appreciate you coming
back on board.
I don't think, I think I'll be
very clear in terms of which
episodes are mine and which
episodes are.
And you know what, this one, I
might upload this to notebook LM
anyway and see what kind of
crazy things they can do and
have fun that way.
But really this is all about
kind of sharing and sharing is
caring and I love you very much.
And I hope you guys are having
an amazing, I hope you've had an
amazing Thanksgiving.
I hope you had an amazing winter
solstice.
I hope you are having and have
had an amazing Hanukkah and I
hope you have an amazing
Christmas.
And I'm sure I will have another
episode before New Year's.
Thank you very much.
Love you.
Like subscribe, comment,
etcetera.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.